You look beautiful.
That's a great outfit.
Thank you!
It's not a dress, it's not pants.
It's kind of a onesie.
It's a onesie.
For an adult, yeah.
It looks great.
Thank you.
It looks like a little
bit of a throwback, too.
Am I wrong?
It's got kind of a 70's thing going on.
It's very retro.
[Conan] Yeah.
I'm so glad you like it.
[Conan] Yeah, I really like it.
I was really excited to come.
I'm like a Conan virgin.
I've never been on the show
before, so I was excited.
(crowd cheers)
Yeah?
(both laugh)
I make women sad.
(laughing)
(clapping)
Yeah. Well, thank you so much-
Thank you!
for being here on this
auspicious occasion.
I know you're also excited-
I'm told you're a big
Johnny Knoxville fan,
big fan of Jackass.
I am.
(laughs) Hi.
You're such a jackass. I love it.
Oh, thank you.
It's so great.
Yeah, I'm kind of - I
like daredevil stuff, so-
Oh yeah?
I get very excited, yeah.
(all laugh)
I don't know where this is going now.
(crowd laughs)
I actually had a little bit of a
jackass moment myself last year.
Do you want to hear it?
Yeah!
Did someone hit you in
the face with a fish?
No, that was not my moment.
No, it was actually in
the Dominican Republic
about a year ago, or a couple years ago,
with my co-star, Johnny
Galecki from the show,
and we decided to rent Vespas,
and I was so excited.
He was driving it and I was in the back,
but I said, you know,
"I want to drive it".
And he goes, "Okay".
And they don't care if
you wear helmets there
or any sort of, you know-
[Johnny] Yeah.
[Conan] Right.
I know you don't, either,
but they don't care.
But you should care.
Yeah, but I don't care.
So I'm like, "Great!"
So I get on, we get the Vespa.
I'm in the front and I am driving around.
I'm so excited, on these little roads,
and I crashed us so bad.
This wall came out of nowhere.
(crowd laughs)
It wasn't even a person or a car.
It was just a wall, but it was kind of-
They're hard to turn.
Yeah, it happens a lot.
[Conan] Yeah.
Yeah, so they were-
(crowd laughs)
[Conan] I love that you're
complaining to Johnny Knoxville
about your accident.
I'm on your side.
This man has had dildos shot at him.
He doesn't care.
I lost a tooth to one.
Anyway, I crashed us really bad.
And that was my one jackass moment.
But it was, it was pretty intense.
We both fell off,
the bike landed on me.
I'm getting sort of an impression
that you do like, the bad boys then?
Are you one of those women
that, that drifts that way?
I do, I tend to go for the bad boy.
The tattooed kind of bad-ass jackass
sort of,
you know, bad guy.
[Andy] The Vespa riders.
(crowd laughs)
yeah, the bad boys
A guy that's in a Vespa gang.
(Conan makes Vespa sounds)
We're coming to your towns.
We'll be there in a long time.
I like the tattoos.
It's the tattoos.
Do you have any tattoos?
Do I have any tattoos?
Yeah?
No, I do not.
None? None under there?
None under where?
Oh, no I was just wondering (laughs)
They'd be obscured by freckle.
I like yours.
(Crowd laughs)
[Johnny] Thank you.
That was a scary one he had in his arm.
[Conan] I don't know.
See, she liked it.
Yeah, no, no I love nothing.
I think tattoos are really cool.
I just think I'm one of those
guys that can't pull it off.
[Kaley] Yeah, no I understand.
Well, that's not nice.
(crowd laughs loudly)
I was just hoping you were going to say-
Kaley why cant you say,
"No, no, you'd be so hot."
(crowd laughs)
Why did you have to say, "Oh
yeah, no, I completely get it."
No, I thought maybe-
That you doing a manly
thing just doesn't work.
No, I thought maybe you had
them secretly underneath,
where you can't see them
not on your hands or...
(crowd laughs)
Well, most people do have them underneath,
but no, I don't.
Andy, you don't have a tattoo?
No, no, no. I can't make
up my mind about things.
(crowd laughs)
[Conan] That's a big commitment.
I always would think like,
what would I be okay with
like when they're rolling me
over in a nursing home bed.
(crowd laughs)
What would I still be proud of?
And I can't think of
a design that's right.
You have to think pretty far ahead
And if it's a band, it better be a band
that's still cool.
Right, no Def Leppard.
[Conan] No Air Supply rules, you know,
(crowd laughs)
it's gotta be something
that's going to last through the ages.
Yeah because, I don't even
know who Air Supply is.
[Conan] Exactly.
(crowd laughs)
Well let me tell you about Air Supply.
Let me tell you about this thing
called REO Speedwagon.
I tell ya.
(crowd laughs)
It was a band for the old times I tell ya.
I'm sorry.
No, that's okay.
I'm not manly and I'm old.
I'm offending you left and right
I don't think I'm ever
being asked back here.
No, no, no you'll be back.
(Conan makes purring noise)
(crowd laughs)
I've got low self esteem.
We're a perfect fit.
(crowd laughs)
Now, I understand that...
Okay. So you're not a good driver are you?
Because you guys shoot
around here on this lot.
We shoot next door to you guys.
And I've actually a couple of times.
I don't know if you've seen it.
I've seen you like when
you go through security,
[Conan] Yeah.
I have almost hit you like three times.
(crowd laughs)
Really?
Am I a pedestrian and you gun the engine?
What happens?
Oh no you're in your car
you've been in your car a couple of times
I've been so paranoid about hitting you.
I got a WB ticket season one.
You know what?
That stunned me.
They have police here.
Yes!
That are Warner Brothers police
that will pull you over for speeding.
Yeah, That happened to me.
Really?
Yes, A couple of years ago.
And they gave you the ticket?
I got a ticket and I'm like,
where are you taking me?
Warner Brothers jail?
Like, where am I going to go?
(crowd laughs)
I'm like write it up!
Go ahead!
You'll appear before judge Daffy Duck.
(crowd laughs)
That was a cartoon from a long time ago.
(crowd roars with laughter)
Please don't hit me.
You're great.
You've got to please come back more often.
Just wander over.
Yeah, I will.
I won't drive over, I'll walk.
I shouldn't be driving anything.
You should never drive again.
The Big Bang Theory, terrific show,
airs Thursdays at 8:00 on CBS
and Hop opens tomorrow.
Yes. Very cute movie.
And you're a voice in Hop.
No I'm person.
Oh, okay.
(crowd laughs)
So you can see, I did a lot of...
I did a lot of research.
(crowd applauds)
No one does their research
like Conan O'Brien.
So it's called Hop.
And it's about the
International House Of Pancakes.
Yes. They were actually, I
think concerned about that.
Originally it was titled IHOP.
So you aren't so off,
but you are it's about an Easter bunny.
It has nothing to do with pancakes.
Okay.
I'm so glad.
Thank you for researching
that, I appreciate it.
I'm old, I'm sexually inadequate,
and completely out of
touch with modern media.
Hey Kaley, it was really
great talking to you.
You're hysterical.
Seriously, you are!
Kaley Cuoco, that was great!